so obviously
as a mathematician and a physicist and
we're all very used to to sort of
playing around with greek letters
omicron's a bit of an unusual one right
as you probably know the the all the
covered variants are named after these
these greek letters and they've been
going along in order uh they got to the
mu variant and then they skipped to and
went to omicron obviously the first
thing you want to ask is why did they
skip skip to well the next letter after
after mew was was new and they did they
thought that was too close to to new as
in something big brand new
one after that was psy which was thought
to be too close to the name of the
chinese president so i thought that was
a bit bad nobody wants to be associated
with the covert variant so they they
went straight to arma cromwell at least
that's the theory that's why they did it
omacross bit of a weird greek letter
it's not one that we see that often in
uh as you know in mass but it does exist
and it does have a bit of history which
i think is is quite
interesting to talk about and certainly
more pleasant to talk about i think than
uh the covered virus well i think we
should go all the way back to the to the
second century uh with ptolemy who was a
you know he wrote this alma guest which
was this big sort of article on
astronomy and he was using uh omicron
there one thing we have to do is we have
to understand a little bit about how the
greeks
wrote their numbers
and they had this kind of alphabetic
system so for example alpha represented
one beta represented two gamma
represented three and so on and they
went like that until they got up to up
to ten so it went up one to nine they
had special letters for 10 special
letters for 20 special letters for 30
and so on and then it would just pile it
all together so i can give you an
example maybe just to illustrate it uh
the number 666 666 devil's number so a
chi
and then i think this is a
psy
and then a zeta and then they'd put a
line over the top and what this means is
so this
represents the number six
this represents the number 60 and this
represents 600.
okay so 666 we put it all together
incidentally omicron does appear in this
okay
it appears as the number 70. okay so
crom which is just more like that
well it's like it's like an o basically
but it also had another interesting use
or people have theorized that it had
another interesting use in ptolemy's
system so what ptolemy did is he also
wanted to he was trying to describe
astronomical systems and he was thinking
about you know sort of the angles in the
sky basically so of course you have 360
degrees you then have um sort of 60
minutes and 60 seconds
that that basically meant he was working
with kind of like a sex decimal um
number system so we needed a way to sort
of write those sort of 1 60th and 1 60
squared i either minutes and the and the
seconds so suppose we want to do like 80
degrees 41 minutes
and three seconds just for
you know pick a random one okay how
would you write how would ptolemy have
written that so he would have done the
80 okay so the symbol for 80 is is pi
so you'd have to put a pi in there they
need to add a new column why is there a
line above it by the way
that's what to distinguish it from the
from the actual letters okay so they put
the lines above it for the numbers okay
80 is is is pi so that goes in the first
column because that's the number of
degrees second column so now we need to
do 41 okay so
40 is mu
and there one is alpha so that's written
like that so that's that's 40 plus one
and then three is is gamma so we put a
gamma in there okay so this this is how
you would have written it this
positional system then you have to ask
the question right well what if i didn't
have any minutes what if i had zero
minutes
okay
so didn't really have a symbol for that
well then so he said what what
ptolemy used was well he used this
symbol which people have said is an
omicron now there's a lot of debate
about this because some people say well
is it an omicron how could it be a
nominee omicron's already 70.
but maybe it was an omicron because you
couldn't put a 70 in any of these
columns anyway because they only went up
to 60 right you know 59. it didn't
really
it could have got away with using an
omicron there it was like the first
symbol available to him that didn't have
a use yeah yeah well it had to use you
could you could put an omicron in this
column right because you could have 70
degrees
but it's but it wouldn't make sense to
have a 17 in either of these columns
right because they only go up to 59.
there's a bit of arguing about this and
another reason people say he might have
used omicron is that the greek word for
nothing called non is orden
right which begins with an omicron in
greek
so so it kind of fitted in so obviously
because of this then people start to
speculate well this does look a little
bit like r0 right a lot actually like a
lot so people think well are they
connected but there's really no evidence
that they are connected in fact almost
certainly not connected it's probably
just a massive coincidence because i
think obviously traditionally people
talk that the
r0 came from much further east
from india so it's almost certainly a
massive coincidence but that's this
ancient use of of omicron
so now i think we need to get a little
bit more modern more recently where is
omicron popped up in the mathematical
literature okay so i know you've come
across donald news before the great sort
of computer scientist from from stanford
obviously we've seen him in the arrow
notation the famous arrow notation which
we use for graham's number so that's
pretty cool he has this really
wonderfully cantankerous paper about
omicron and its use in the mathematical
which i love this paper it's so
it's just so angry it's great
i've got it here so this is this is the
paper well i say it's modern but i mean
it was came out the year after i was
born so it's not that modern 1976.
here we are so the title of the paper is
big omicron big omega and big theta the
reason he wrote this paper was because
he was really getting a bit fed up with
the way people were misusing omicron in
the mathematical literature and omegas
as well actually and he basically
decided that somebody needed to fix the
literature to sort out all the language
that people were using and normalize and
that's the point of his cantankerous
paper which literally just sets
the sort of rules of what people should
be using so what is omicron and i guess
omega and theta
to donald news
well let me explain it's to do with how
sort of fast things grow if i say that
something is
omicron big omicron some people call it
big o but
he calls it omicron so we're going to go
with that if something says
that
big omicron n squared what does that
mean
this means all the functions
which are bounded above so that they're
essentially smaller than things that
grow like n squared so let me let me do
it graphically so maybe that will
explain so suppose
you've got
we're going to send n to infinity okay
so we're going to make it really really
big so let me just draw n squared okay
grows like that okay or this could be
some multiple of n squared this could be
some you know some number m times n
squared now all the functions that this
means what does this actually mean it
means all the functions which don't
quite grow as big as that they don't get
they don't get as big as quickly as that
so they might do this so they might go
above in you know small values of them
but eventually when you get big enough
they don't grow as fast they always stay
below
some curve which is a multiple of n
squared
so there's always a curve which is some
multiple of n squared which they stay
behind and that's what this this
notation means
okay now it's important notation for
sort of uh thinking about how sort of
systems
you know maybe if you've got an
algorithm and you want to work out how
how sort of efficient it is so we've got
to sort out end things and you want to
know well
how quickly does how many steps do i
need to use is it order ends is it this
is it this this order n squared or is it
is it some other something else it gives
you a feel for that so it's really
important in that kind of thing and so
obviously you can put any function in
here right okay so you could do order n
cubed uh or the you know or any any
other function that log n anything right
and you're just basically saying that
the the functions that you're talking
about don't grow as fast as some
multiple of that thing what about
the other things that he's talked about
in the paper well they're kind of quite
simple so he has
you can imagine something like omega of
n squared that's kind of the other way
around the other things that go faster
than it okay the other side of the line
the other side of the line so something
like this so this would basically say
there was stuff which is also growing
like
you know some other n here that they're
always bigger than some other number
times n squared so they stay the other
side of the line they can always find
something which is growing like n
squared some multiple of n squared which
and this guys will grow faster then
theta which is the last one of the list
that means you're talking about all the
functions which are
above something that grows like n
squared so multiple of n squared and
below
some other multiple of n squared so
they're kind of bounded on either side
these ones tell you all the functions
that are below
these ones tell you all the functions
that are above
and these ones tell you all the
functions that are in between
for some choice of m and m and and
primed as i've written it so with
omicron and omega we don't need two
lines do we because they don't have to
be between but with theta there needs to
be two
two lines to define out exactly exactly
so the theta's kind of more precise it
tells you it's really telling you an
awful lot of information that it's
really really growing like some multiple
of n squared so it's really trapped
between
you know that group two different growth
rates which are very alike uh whereas
the other two sort of just give you an
upper bound or a lower bound
there's another
area where these are used you don't just
have to take things to infinity to use
this notation you can take things to to
constants or to zero and that's where i
tended to come across this notation this
this omicron and you could say well what
is omicron of x squared as x goes to
zero
this basically means all the functions
which are smaller than x squared
okay
so then the bounded above by x squared
so things like x g as x goes to zero so
you can think things like x cubed or x
to the four so as x goes to zero they're
always going they're not growing as fast
as x squared so it's the same kind of
idea so for example let's
let's draw the graph again let's draw
something which goes like x squared
which is
which company's 4 times x squared or 5
times x squared it's just a multiple of
x squared
and we want all the functions which are
we're going to x equals 0 now so we're
interested in what's happening down here
okay we're in the functions that are
like an x cubed which down here is is
growing more slowly
okay so all the functions which are
trapped down here but we're interested
in what's happening down down below okay
near zero because eventually x cube will
over
in the other direction it'll overtake
yeah absolutely absolutely yeah so you
couldn't have it it's only a statement
about what happens to x equals zero so
yes you see here so here we're
interested in staying below as we go to
large values here we're interested in
staying below as you go to small values
but you can use the same notation for
each it just says you're bounded above
by by this thing by these this functions
which go like x squared or two times x
squared or three times x squared okay
and of course you can apply the same the
omega and the theta language there too
and this is really common in physics
actually to use this we use it in
perturbation thing one thing we do in
physics is is perturbation theory which
is where you take
small stuff so you see to actually do
anything you take really small
quantities and you
expanded it you sort of consider the the
first correction in that quantity
something's like let me give you an
example uh quantum electrodynamics we
have a small number in quantum
electrodynamics which is the fine
structure constant which is one over one
three seven that's a small number so
what you can do is you can calculate
things to some sort of degree of
accuracy in the front structure constant
so if we want like roughly a one percent
accuracy we only need to take the first
correction that's linear in the fine
structure constant and then we can go to
higher order to things that go like the
square of the fine structure constant
that would give us like one percent of
one percent accuracy roughly and you can
go higher and use this perturbation
theory and that's how you do physics
that's how you do physics you can't read
without perturbation theory physicists
are useless
okay right so so we really need and
obviously this kind of language which is
telling you how
what are all the things that you're
sweeping onto the carpet that you're
ignoring what are all how fast are they
growing what are they bounded above by
if we were talking about something like
the fine structure constant we might say
oh those terms are order alpha squared
you know that they so we put an omicron
alpha squared or omega alpha cubed they
had to think so everything that we've
swept under the carpet that we're
ignoring they're bounded above by this
thing okay functions which grow like
this thing
and that's the idea of a
so this is this is the use of omicron in
um in in math and physics when they
named this new variant omicron did you
straight away go oh yeah i know that
symbol i use it all the time in physics
well i don't see this is the thing
funnily enough i don't think it does get
used i never thought i've used this all
the time right this this notation is so
common right i use my lectures i use it
all the time when i'm writing stuff
i never thought of it as an armored
crown really i never it never occurred
to me that it was enormous oh so oh
right you know but it's an overcrowd
fairly quick to donate that's what it is
i should think of it as an overcome
which i'm more than happy to do now
i saw some debate on social media people
say oh we need all need to start writing
papers with omnichromes now everyone's
like everybody's already doing it it's
like you just didn't realize so i think
that's quite cool
waiting for your chance to talk about it
what book is this here this is a book
called the almagest by ptolemy and this
particular edition is very very old 1515
is the publication date for this it is
the first published edition of this book
the book itself was actually written in
about 150 a.d so
i was asked on twitter to calculate the
number of sorskov two particles that the
particles that caused kovid19 how many
they were in the world and so i did the
calculation and it turns out that there
are few enough to fit inside a regular
can of coke